[Music]
[Music]
and and there's so
moving the cloud they want you to go to
the cloud
and they're selling it as a great idea
just you don't need your stuff just give
it to us we'll keep it on the cloud
it's fine you don't have to and you're
like really but those are my pictures
and my
just give keep it on the cloud you pay a
little rent
to have it up on the cloud and the way
they're going to talk you into this
is that you get to have a smaller device
because you don't need to keep the stuff
on it you know
that's why okay like this somebody gave
me this iphone this is where an iphone
is right now okay
now it's going to when they when they
tell you you want to keep it on the
cloud they're going to say this is this
is the iphone now the off the next
iphone is is just going to be this
that's good it's just going to be this
and it's just going to be this
thing because you need this to store all
your movies and stuff
but you're just going to have this and
you just rub and go oh i want to see tom
cruise and he'll just
tom cruise will be all around your face
and then you want to see you know selma
hayek and then you take it and
that's how it's going to work i'll give
you 10 000
for that thing right now
meanwhile at the university of nebraska
computer scientists have developed a
version of the internet
that is up to 100 times faster than the
current system
according to analysts those using the
new system to log on to america online
will now be disconnected in three one
thousandth of a second
hey what's going on
it's bill byrne it's the monday morning
podcast sorry for the
[ __ ] march 2nd i'm going to tell you
something
oh i'm coming out of the gate this week
people i just [ __ ]
i just did like eight minutes a great
[ __ ] eight minutes a great [ __ ]
riff the whole goddamn thing and then i
look down and the [ __ ] goddamn
stupid ass [ __ ] thing isn't even on
you know why this is the exact same
[ __ ] device i had the olympus ls10
now it's the olympus 14. and wouldn't
you [ __ ] know
they couldn't just leave well enough
alone they got to add like 20 [ __ ]
steps
and some stupid broads [ __ ] voice in
there telling me what i know i'm doing
so i [ __ ] riff for like eight [ __ ]
minutes and i find out the thing isn't
even [ __ ] recording
i i [ __ ] i hate technology
okay i absolutely i don't understand why
do we keep
going forward all right we got enough
[ __ ] this is as comfortable as it's
gonna [ __ ] get why can't we just have
this [ __ ]
and this is how it [ __ ] works and
when you figure something out
that's you know how it [ __ ] works
jesus [ __ ] christ i told you guys and
i [ __ ] will never stop
bitching about these things i [ __ ] uh
was talking on my podcast saying how you
know i needed a new pair of [ __ ]
headphones one week right
so uh some [ __ ] person who listens to
the podcast
ended up sending me a pair of [ __ ]
wireless [ __ ] headphones
wireless [ __ ] headphones and i gotta
tell you i've never had more [ __ ]
problems with something in my life
you [ __ ] sitting there my whole life
headphones [ __ ] work
you plug them into something that's
charged the headphones
the amount of [ __ ] times i sat there
with my phone listening to [ __ ] music
my phone is charged and then the
headphones went out and i couldn't
listen it's just [ __ ]
why did you add that step electronic
pencil sharpeners and all that [ __ ] and
now it's just something that's gonna
[ __ ]
drives me up the other one the other
pencil sharpener you could buy a pencil
sharpener once and you're gonna have
anything for a hundred [ __ ] years
and little kids could walk up and be
like that's this was my grandfather's
well he used to you know [ __ ] sharpen
pencils and then
when he built stuff when we still had
good wood in this country
right it wasn't all wet because it was
brand new [ __ ] trees it was old [ __ ]
oh my god i was in such a great [ __ ]
mood
it's completely changed the whole
[ __ ] vibe of this goddamn thing
anyways let me relax calm down let me
try to get back to where i was i was in
such a [ __ ] great mood because i'm
back out here and lost
congolese let me make sure this thing's
recording
let me make sure everything's okay in
the goddamn nerve center here
you know [ __ ]
but i can't believe it's been a quarter
century since i made my television
debuts all
different back man you know it was back
then
i remember if you wanted to take a
picture you would use a camera
not a telephone
as a matter of fact if you use the
telephone people would look at you
odd
you know
you stay still like
what about in the old days when they
took pictures of you
way back you know where they pulled that
thing and exploded and stuff
i got a picture of my great grandfather
the thing took six hours
uh to take your picture and a is a
picture of my great grandfather one they
only had
every guy had one picture back then
and it's just him like
[Applause]
i gotta get back feed them hugs
who's gonna feed the hogs
somebody gotta feed them hogs now
in the future of course it'll be
different 50 years from now
people will be going like hey you want
to see a hundred thousand pictures of my
great grandfather
i got him right here class everything he
did every day of his life
why do we get excited when the cell
phone rings every other phone in your
life that rings the pain in the ass
right
who was that what do they want did you
tell them i'm here
but when you're out with people and
somebody's cell phone goes off everybody
gets all fizzy about it is that my
phone is that your phone
hey that's funky town that's my ring
i gotta make a move to a town that's
right for me
why are you getting excited because your
cell phone is ringing it's just a phone
and you know that the call is not
important
you know how you know the call's not
important they're calling you
what two things do you say after every
phone call of your life who is that
nobody what they want nothing
one thing i've noticed about these cell
phones we seem to have much less
interest in the people that are actually
with us
their value seems to be dropping quite
dramatically
some people kind of want to let you know
that you know don't you have a friend
that every time you sit down with them
they got to take the phone out
and put it on the table
what is that message you're not the only
option that i have
i got text message internet email if you
want my full attention go out on the
street and call me on this phone
that's where it's happening for me
people get you know they i don't know
it's so dramatic
when the when they're static you're
breaking up
hang on what is this apollo 13 you're at
the mall take it easy
you're talking to somebody at the food
court getting a pretzel
that you can see from the escalator as
you're coming down
uh i'm very surprised and impressed
about this that you you've
built kind of like a a twitter following
yeah so i'm an
internet sensation whoa now i didn't
take you for a guy that would know about
that kind of i know all about that stuff
really when did you start twitter
two weeks ago really but this is what i
know i did it for the oscars the guy
told me how to do it i was watching the
oscars
and you know how horrible those were and
so it was pretty easy to do just jokes
constantly on how horrible everyone was
you know
and uh and uh you know and some of the
things were nice like
it was nice to see kirk douglas of
course you know and he had that terrible
stroke
which didn't affect his comic timing at
all and uh
but uh so i twittered and i ended up
twittering 190 tweets
whoa and which is it turns out it's way
too much really
so people started telling me to stop
anyways
get this just earlier this happened
right before we came on the
uh on the show i walked out here uh i'm
in some kind of twitter feud with steve
martin
i know that i know that steve also
actively twitters yeah yeah so this is
what happened dig this
you know how to tweet no you don't know
how to tweet no
where you've been so so uh
so i he writes a tweet i misunderstand
it
i replied i just heard what he said what
he said
okay well this is what he said
i'm not really that great at it but
he said uh he said has anybody
seen my hat now
looked every four for it i can't find my
hat
right so i say was it a brown fedora
with a red
hat band but what i didn't know is he
sent a twit
pick
stop right there let me just say
if this is an example of twitter
communication
it's invaluable
what do you think i should answer it
this is the last thing you said to me he
goes uh
this just came in nine seconds ago he
goes
still mulling over this tweet from norm
to me
it's so enigmatic is it a put down
i i don't honestly i i mean he lost a
hat
right yeah and then you responded is it
with a red
hat band yeah i don't none of this makes
any sense yeah it's a generational thing
i guess so